with your middle finger say did you said
quote yelled it and then said
you as you drove away and all that
public there heard it and saw it so that
is just s of the conduct 101 step out of
the car is flipping off the cops Free
Speech
absolutely but that didn't stop this
officer a newly released video shows
Vermont Trooper Jay rigan pulling over
Gregory bombard two times in less than
10 minutes in 2018 the first time
bombard denied giving the officer the
bird and the officer let him go but as
he drove away he did flash his middle
finger sparking his arrest oh my God
hands in the hood come
on put your hand behind your back oh my
God the disorderly conduct charges were
eventually dismissed but bombard now has
a First Amendment case against the
officer and the state of Vermont and he
just might win courts have consistently
held that flipping off police is
protected speech but that hasn't stopped
them from arresting people who give them
the bird over and over and
over